now if someone asked you
what's happening to gas prices natural
gas prices you'd probably say and i
certainly would have until a few weeks
ago they're really high but here's the
thing actually in the uk right now they
are very low now let me just take you
through what's going on here this
is essentially the wholesale gas price
so any gas that you want to buy one day
on uh and this is the price in europe so
north europe the ttf it's kind of the
dutch benchmark now have a look at uk
prices so same thing for the uk look the
red line tracks what's happening in
europe up until a couple of months ago
and since then there's been enormous
divergence in the uk wholesale gas
prices for day ahead delivery the next
day delivery have gone down to
incredibly low levels by comparison with
recent history so what's going on here
well you need to kind of take a step
back and look at what how the gas market
basically fits together so we need to
look at a map here and to remember the
fact that most of european gas imports
come from russia they are trying to
reduce that obviously but you need to
find the gas from elsewhere where can
you get it we can get a bit more maybe
from north africa you can get maybe a
bit more from azerbaijan but the
majority of that extra gas or that
replacement gas has to come in the form
of lng tankers liquefied natural gas
from the us uh from qatar and in order
to dock those tankers you need places
for them to go terminals i've
highlighted in green all of the
terminals that we have in europe and
what you can probably make out is
there's very few of them in this area
that most needs the gas north europe you
can see one there in poland there's one
in belgium one in france but not enough
and the reason for for focus on the uk
is that we have three terminals in this
country and a lot of people were hoping
the lng could come in in the tankers to
uk and then could get piped across to
the continent and that's basically
what's been happening recently you've
got two pipelines going from the uk
through to europe the uk is acting as a
kind of land bridge so the lng docks
here it goes across the uk and then goes
out through the interconnector and this
other one the baxton pipeline and if you
look at what's happened in terms of
those pipeline flows they've basically
been at max levels recently so pumping
it as fast as they can
but it's not fast enough and those
pipelines aren't basically big enough to
get all of that lng across and the
upshot is we have a lot of lng coming
into this country liquified natural gas
coming in but not enough of it can get
out through to europe and the upshot is
we can't have more gas in this country
knocking around than we really know what
to do with and that's what brings us
back to this chart a lot of gas here no
one's sure what to do with it so the
price is very low right now who would
have thought now at this stage you're
probably asking right how soon until
that's reflected in my bill and here of
course
there's a catch because the energy
companies say that they base their
prices primarily not on these day ahead
markets but on futures markets looking
out the next month or indeed further so
although these prices are down at the
lowest they've been in 18 months when
you look at futures markets well this is
looking at year ahead prices for gas
what investors think is going to happen
in a year's time actually the uk is very
similar to north europe now that could
be wrong it might not be but at the
moment that's what our bills are based
on and that's why despite the fact that
there's so much gas in in the uk despite
the fact that the stock small markets
put it at the lowest price essentially
in 18 months
still we've got very high record high
bills